sie kennen wahrscheinlich auch den
spruch ich bin zwar heterosexuelle aber
es gibt diesen einen mann für den ich
schwul werden würde
und jetzt stehe ich hier neben ihm
[Musik]
mein name ist fabian und ich bin noch
jungfrau mein erstes mal möchte ich mit
den grünen erleben aber ist das wirklich
die richtige entscheidung ich bin
nächstes jahr ja erst wähler sozusagen
warum sollte ich jetzt die grünen wählen
wenn ich dann wieder angela merkel
christian exakt ist sie wieder angela
merkel kommen sie ja hinter den kulissen
ist das auch schon durch ist es hier sie
könnten auch sich nur gab mir kriegen
und dann und dann was machen wir dann
dann haben wir beide angst kann man die
wahl der spitzenkandidaten unter das
motto stellen wir suchen einen mann für
katrin göring eckardt
das würde ich so überhaupt nicht sehen
ich bin aber es ist so ich finde es ist
eine gute auswahl unter den männern das
schade dass ich keine frau weiter
gefunden hat ja ich habe eine
textaufgabe für sie mitgebracht aus der
schule die habe ich nie verstanden wenn
drei männer und eine frau sich der
grünen urwahl stellen und die frau
gewinnen muss wie schätzen sie dann ihre
chancen ein
geht so da bin ich mit ihnen einer
meinung
bei der csu dürfte niemand von der cdu
reden aber hier bei den grünen ist man
noch gastfreundlich der offizielle
vertreter der cdu spricht gerade das
grußwort was halten sie von der
kretschmann
herr kretschmann hat eine herausragende
position bei den grünen das ist keine
frage ein bestimmtes charisma wir haben
davon nicht so wahnsinnig viele leute
dass wir das schlimmste können und
insofern ein einzelphänomen von der
person her seine politik muss er bald
wollen sie ja also zusammengefasst sagen
sie die grünen haben eigentlich kein
charisma außer herr kretschmann ein
das ist nicht wahr haben sie doch gerade
gesagt nein ich habe mein einzel
versehen doch das hat mir gesagt einmal
da so lege ich mich jetzt versagt dann
korrigiere ich dass da hingehen und die
grünen sind sehr sexy zeigen sie doch
mal übrigens mit dem kraft also die
heute-show schickt ihr uns jetzt nur
noch die praktikanten früher kamen dass
an der horster wir gehen natürlich zu
den wichtigen parteien aber die
praktikanten gehen natürlich zu den
grünen deswegen wichtig
dann hätten sie denn für mich zeit auch
das haben wir mal wenn die party so
durchhängen sowie mitte hängt ja jetzt
schon durch er ist ja nicht parat die
jetzt hat er gearbeitet aber mit danach
weiß ich nicht ob ich noch da hab ja ja
ja in ihrem alter rittmann mitternachts
noch fit sein oder jetzt sind wir ja
eigentlich schon im gespräch
nehmen sie mir nehmen sie mir als erster
wähler doch mal die angst vor dem grünen
kommen sie hier genießen sie schmeißen
sie sich an die brust von starken grünen
frauen wir feiern heute 30 jahre habe
ich noch mehr angst da müssen sie durch
gucken sich unsere männer an die sind da
durchgegangen sie kennen wahrscheinlich
auch den spruch ich bin zwar
heterosexuell
aber es gibt diesen einen mann für den
ich schwul werden würde und jetzt stehe
ich hier neben ihnen haben
[Musik]
oli stich soziales bin ich auch nicht
milchreis und sieht man sich den auf
oliver welke lieber lieber als mich
kennen sie ja gar nicht vielleicht
kreutzmann bartmann würden was ich nicht
für 16 holz
dankeschön das nehme ich als kompliment
ist komplementär es wirkt die
kinderarbeit
vielleicht sollten sie sich den bart
abrasieren dann würde man sie nicht für
50 halten ja war wissen die politiker
müssten sowieso älter und würdige wirken
aber sagen sie doch jetzt einfach gar
nichts dann habe ich schon einen grund
die grünen zu wählen
für für lau oder wie soll ich jetzt hier
die lackierung in hand ja na dann dankt
schon einmal in die kamera zusammen
[Musik]
ja it-service bruns ich spreche mit
jürgen wie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
ja haben immer versucht das gerät aus
und wieder einzuschalten hat nichts
gebracht verstehe
probieren sie doch mal den kanal der
heute show auf youtube zu abonnieren
und im zweifel ruhig auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung